people in a Southwest Las Vegas
neighborhood concerned after a load of
recyclables was seemingly dumped on one
of their streets yeah Madison Kimbrough
looking into this live from the area
near Rainbow and Cactus to explain what
exactly happened here Madison
yeah you would have never guessed that
this area was covered in trash a couple
hours ago and you can take a look as
Republic Services was here that cleaned
up the mess but since then we have
talked to neighbors and community
members frustrated voicing their
concerns directly to 8 News Now
Saturday quite a surprise for residents
in this Mountain's Edge Community where
Public Services dumpster and what was
inside recyclables dumped all over the
street not only an eyesore but the odor
was bad too neighbors here especially
those that live along the wall where the
trash was dumped want answers there were
trash outside and we didn't know what
happened I we thought there was a crash
or somewhere people were swerving
et cetera Etc it's broken glass
everywhere at the entrance and exit to
the community I mean I'll get a broom if
I have to and sweep it up myself after
residents called and we were alerted of
the trash we went to see it for
ourselves and found that Ecotech
environmental started cleaning up the
mess Monday afternoon
now the reason for the spill Republic
Services sharing with me the door to one
of their trucks malfunctioned causing
the mess now neighbors here are happy
that it's just all clear and that the
smell is almost gone reporting in
Southwest Valley Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now
all right thanks Madison while it's
still unclear as to why it took a little
over 48 hours to clear the debris the
company States they are committed to
being a good neighbor and ensure that
the area is clean and free of debris